how you doing
good how are you i'm doing excellent
listen i'm obviously going to start with
uh congratulating you i thought you did
such a great job in the movie
thank you that's her interview
um uh you've obviously you've worked
you've made other projects before
i'm curious this is obviously a much
different experience
because you know it's a big hollywood
movie what
what how did making this movie compared
to the
other projects you've been a part of
well i mean sure it was really different
because
um i mean i'm 12 years old only
and i'm already acting in hollywood was
like
very amazing and also very different
because before i shoot it in germany
or greece and everything i mean it was
also terrific
and but now being opposite to tom haynes
is sure such a big deal so um it was a
great experience
before a shooting began what was the
sequence
that you were nervous to film and which
was the sequence you were super excited
to film
well i mean was excited about the whole
movie but um
i was nervous to bite him like to buy
tom hanks
because it was unfortunately on the
first or second day i think on the
second day
and so we did not know each other very
good and i started or had to start with
biting him
so that was kind of funny and then also
i was really excited to shoot with the
horses and to get to know them
sure um you are there's obviously a
sequence in the film
where there's a little bit of a shootout
which is you know
filming an action set piece what what
what might surprise people
to learn about making a scene like that
well it might surprise them that
actually the
whole thing is visual effect so
it is actually that um
i mean you shoot parts of it but
the whole thing is actually made up with
computers
so that might be interesting for people
that
um the pang and everything the sounds
the hearing the guns and
everything is actually all fake
you're pulling back the curtain on movie
magic
i do right um i i love the old west
and i love watching westerns like this
um obviously you're much younger than i
am what were you surprised to learn
about the old west
and about that time period that maybe
really surprised you
well i mean one thing was really that i
learned
a lot from the native americans what was
their story
and um before i make sure it's because
it is actually the story of america
i didn't know quite as well about it so
um i think i really learned a lot about
the native american people
and about their story and their way of
thinking in the circle
and about what really happened because i
think there are many stories you can
tell about what
really happened but it was interesting
to hear from the people who really got
through completely my last question for
you
um obviously making this must have been
the most amazing experience
when you think back on the shoot is
there a day or two that you will always
remember
i will always remember halloween how was
zayn those favorite song of mine
which was from um
from the son of music and it was called
like you know the song
doe with dear female dear
and i guess you know that song and and
there was a very amazing day because
we celebrated halloween and before it
was very sad
because i thought oh no i'm not with my
friends and everything but then it was
one of the most or one of the best days
i had in my life because
just everybody was there and was great
and we were selecting treats and
covering a pumpkin while shooting so
that was really fun
uh that's amazing on that note i'm just
going to say congratulations
um you did such a great job like i said
good luck with your rest of your
interviews
thank you a lot